Speaker 1: Well, this you have to see to believe
or maybe not.
Donald Trump wants you and me taxpayers to
pay for his bogus special master.
That never should have even been granted.
So let's back up and I'll tell you what's
going on.
Business Insider Headline Trump wants to split
the cost of the special master with the government,
but the DOJ wants him to pay for it.
A judge granted Trump's request for a special
master, but the DOJ has appealed the decision.
Now, remember, Judge Eileen Cannon granted
Trump's request for a special master.
A special master would take control of all
the documents seized from Trump's Mar a Lago,
would review them, and would see, are there
documents here that shouldn't be part of the
FBI investigation because they are in some
way privileged?
Are there documents here that shouldn't be
part of the investigation?
Maybe because they contain medical information
or whatever the case may be.
That granting of a special master has been
found by legal experts who have weighed in
to be absolutely absurd and raises major questions
about Judge Eileen Cannon.
Fine, but then we get to the question of who's
going to pay for this.
A new court filing shows the two sides disagree
over who should pay for the special master.
The government said Trump as the party requesting
the special master should bear the cost.
But Trump wants the government to split it
with him, even though the DOJ does not agree.
The filing also outlined disagreements between
the government and Trump's legal team regarding
how the entire special master process would
unfold.
No surprise there, Trump's team proposed to
split evenly the professional fees and expenses
of the Special Master and any professionals,
support staff and expert consultants engaged
at the master's request.
But the Justice Department has already started
reviewing the seized materials, doesn't want
a special master appointed and disagreed.
The Government's position is that as the party
requesting, the Special Master Plaintiff should
bear the additional expense of the Special
Master's work.
This actually could be so hypothetical if
Judge Eileen Cannon is coming around to the
fact that her decision to grant the Special
Master was the wrong decision.
If she's coming around to that, this could
be a way to get out because we know Trump
doesn't pay for stuff and the decision could
be made.
You pay for all of it or there is no special
master.
That would be one thing that to look at that
would be interesting.
But the whole premise of Trump's argument
and the judge ruling with him is that his
documents must be protected and sorted through.
The government doesn't have such a concern
if the government believes that they were
authorized to obtain the documents, that everything
was done on the up and up, all of those things.
And and indeed, remember that classified and
top secret documents, those aren't Trump's
documents.
Those are government documents.
If Trump wants to make the case they are his
documents and they shouldn't be released and
all of these different things, it should be
him.
It should be he who actually ends up paying
for it.
And we don't know if that's actually the direction
it's going to go.
It doesn't make sense that Trump gets to dictate
to the government what of its own documents.
Because remember, as William Barr has said
this, who else has said so many Republicans
have now said, these aren't Trump's documents.
These are government documents.
These are the people's documents, for lack
of a better term.
It doesn't make sense that Trump gets to tell
the government what they need to do with their
own documents, and then they also pay for
that.
It is Trump who has to get to do that.
He wants the special master.
He should have to pay for it.
It doesn't make sense to keep deferring to
him in this way.
Now what's the strategy?
The strategy is just to delay.
That's the strategy and it's a well known
legal strategy.
You often it applies often in criminal trials
where most criminal defense attorneys will
tell you the longer we can delay, the better
for everybody.
Number one, and this is I sort of say this
tongue in cheek, but also not the more motions
to delay that a lawyer can file and succeed
with.
The more the lawyer gets to bill, all else
being equal and continue extending, extending,
extending and listen.
At the end of the day, yeah.
Lawyers want to make money.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money?
Speaker 1: Yeah, sometimes people want to
make money, but that's not to suggest lawyers
would unethically do that.
There's also the legal explanation which lawyers
have told me, which is the longer you can
delay a criminal case.
Witnesses might die.
Witnesses recollection becomes less accurate.
Documents might be lost, the evidence might
be misplaced.
And it, generally speaking, favors defendants
to delay, delay, delay in criminal trials.
Laws might change.
This applies more to like white collar.
And even though, generally speaking, the way
you are prosecuted is based on what the law
was at the time.
It's still not going to hurt you if the law
changes in a way that is fair.
All these different things can happen.
So that's the strategy here.
DeLay as much as possible, period.
And it's like a kid trying to delay bedtime.
Well, you know, I need to use the bathroom
and I'm getting thirsty and.
Oh, I don't know.
I need to check what's my lunch tomorrow?
And now I'm hungry.
And then.
Oh, well, I got to brush my teeth again.
It's the same type of thing.
And now Trump wants you to pay for it and
hopefully that is rejected.